I'm place like the laughing mean like i am i don't know.
I am i'm just sort of was the element i wouldn't among them to grow up anywhere else probably because this is a
benevolent and. We had not travelled with them. So he's exposed to.
Well one of the real of the real things i would have been exposed to was drugs.
But not at that festival tone that was lighter. So to be nice to come out on my side that.
Up until i actually left time and then came back that i would never offered drugs.
And i wouldn't you know had to stop they had but truth
or lies he's a plain young students he is i would never have offered drugs by anybody. But by brad.
They were and i knew that i ran up there. I think just. Well. I've been lucky. There was a lot of strange paper.
That sort of taught them that i had to be very careful of who i talk to a food i got to know so that sort of mad them
or that much better in their logs at the news that you know if you didn't trust anybody everybody.
But then again requested.
We were lucky we had yeah people would come into the past
and that sort of things that i sort of grew up with the blood starts of the fates you know we were
when we went to paradise valley and had dinner with friends out there that we've got to now.
We had people come here off the communes to have meals with us we find a tangible and took the children with.
That's why i think i got to know that there was a muslim just the right law and in life that.
There was too so it's do iton.
And bad so it's could be quite pleasant if you get it down to the two girls of the two girls sleeping his in his mum.
But the married and i've went in there leave and never the four lot. Two husbands and the two walks us.
Got jobs in these memos that. They caught happy leaving them behind with the sky because she's at college and.
That was her choice that she you know. And that she wanted to have a bright a life from newman.
She was probably the one with whom she doesn't know the other saw the name because she was born.
I stayed in the oldest and. Bipolar rock in the. So she and i sort of mean then as it is now not as a boss before.
That was probably the other thing that was a fear from me was before the fist of when your kids could be waianae out
and you knew that that were the talking to her or not to learn our friend. Where if they were gone for ten minutes.
You were concerned as you know that you know when a rabbi who's got them. And. Because that was a.
I fear for my personally having stray young children away before that.
That was probably a different name been from my that.
Before the festival of my children could be gone for an hour up destroyed. After that if i was gone for five minutes.
Would be countess i with i want my life in that respect. That i had to be more aware where my children were than i was.
Before on young people on drugs. It would have to be you know i know i said this man it's in the moment.
I think the opposite i've got a lot of fond memories of the festival and after that. That would have to pay.
I think the saddest thing that i had to say is you know. I thought been blown away i thought drugs.
And it would be the talk of random overlap and so i come on we're going to get right out of life in this.
It would have to be the thing that i would judge him in that. Yes that it wasn't the festival.
Now i wouldn't side that not the heavy stuff.
After the first or when i think we found little pops of marijuana growing. But there was what. Ran the blood.
But we're probably having a smart. A ram. That's their business and that is their consent. But i think.
Then it came to dealing.
But i think that's probably any happened sort of scientists are nice the last ten years where we've got the deal are
coming into town and. And that sort of thing we have in mind.
That's the sign was anything else a surprise if you've just got it right we're going to have are our cigarette of
marijuana or whatever the i call it. That is their business.
But i do think that alone should be drawn somewhere that people are selling it to other people's children.
That that is a very big.
Concern ammonia and said i don't know what i would have done had heart of sort of had them offering it to moan
but i can side that. It never happened until now it's happening that they've gone by and they're coming back on.
And my ass sort of rising up to them now in the straight and sighing. They want to bow out but up until then.
It was never offered to them but.
That would be not saddest thing about naman is that it is that they are not so young logs being destroyed bill at those
who do not know couldn't say i have. But i think.
If you leave here and in such a small community yes it touches you personally just to say. Anyone's child.
You can stand back and side well. I don't care because you do care. And i'm not just sad. You know.
It is it's really and truly sad to say it because some of those kids up there are so young and i think if we you know.
Just like to say the deal is for it. I can align all. I'm sure would be that.
That is their problem then we've got it and no i don't know. I don't know how to fix it.
And i think that's the agra biting pad up at the you darn i had to fix it yourself
and you don't know if anyone else can fix today that you know for sure. I think i think it.
It is just that now i had to do was that any of us. You know we can talk about it and so i will.
And i suppose we can also the tron blind mother paper for it but that's not fixing it is that. You know. And we dug.
That's what i know i think that is why we do try and pass the blind on this one all that mana someone else inside.
If we didn't have a festival to put in the pap and if we do. Can do this so that what.
Wouldn't happen but it's happened.
And that's not the point we brought up and we just sat helpless we didn't know what to do a battle.
We will never be able to fix it i don't know.
But it is a concern that would have to be not because that really my saddest thing about leaving newman and saying it.
No i just think living in new haven is right. A life has been good.
And it's because i live up to our good has been a bad. Read trait. Beautiful children and.
I've had a good job i work with good paper and i so the lock in general has been good and i force that. And i think.
And i don't think i could have been happier if i'd lived anywhere outside. In them. Surprise. What is it you know.
Not really. And i just think it's. Neiman's name been and then think up with well.
I had this fraud but it's just it's got a. There's a cad to it but not to say it if you haven't got a sense of p.m.u.
Deadly feel. You've got a very prepared to be apt to laugh at things if you take not serious and human is not for you.
That's not your place of that documents iow you believe do you do you think god guess i am going to sense.
The i'm forgetting. Now. You know really i mean i haven't got a funny story and i think. I've got.
Really you know i'd have to think about it the could be lots of funny things that happened.
In my life that you could like that
but nothing comes to mind i think is probably what i'll probably during the first of
when i didn't run down the street but not have a bobbing along you know especially not the bet that is
but it's nothing really it's lots of funny things that happened.
I've anything in particular that i could sort of cyber yes that was probably
when you've gone out i know you're telling that story but you know. Thank you. Oh well. I'm charlie said and.
I was very very busy doing the first festival i mean i was unable to go on and. I have such a full column job.
Miking the street. Preventable and claim enough for everyone and. The total job was a. Quite a handful and.
On have a bit of other. Care securities to do. Be sawed up at my lady or. My only more fold i would tighten up with.
Just looking off to the straight and the. Particularly the garbage.
So much of what you read my memories back over the festival and yeah. I'm not quite such a. Quite a few.
Norse new people that kind and. Quite a few of them are still here.
Why are there look to most of those who want to leave here and do the right thing that they're not really happy with.
Having another festival. So i say yeah. I think i might feel.
This quite a lot goes on that shouldn't be going on and i not might not feel happy about it you. You must know. You.
Well if i know as much as i certainly would have been very much of a guy i said.
Because for so many things went on of particularly the way people walk from.
Choir this in the cradle quite additions walking from where they lived and came to.
Share rooms in that i mean it didn't matter who you were or what you were i. I walked completely on kind of and.
At least australian like with a bit of tile.
And some of the other places that some of the tents and things that they're going to walk past well where mum
and dad was leading the way of course i promptly stopped and turned the children back the other way i
or so they wouldn't say what was going on in the team. Yeah. I changed the direction and.
It was so much happening to happen then. In the drug needling pot. Where there were so many so many used needles.
Even lying a bath and working in the dump ever seems well. It was no.
It was no problem at all who lay there we were trying to claim that. Claim the dump and wait so i can live.
And he could come across.
I don't know and he was in one place without any trouble and move on a bit further and come across more.
Still with the needle in them.
It would have been a very risky thing to wave
and put your hands over for you to any way any of the neighbors what you didn't know was already there.
That was all first of all talk on the other. It's been the.
You're just being a simon till just recently when they dumped us. A chinese hands a bit for recycling people.
But the neighborhood. Right up until just recently. And as i got there.
Times for a bit of recycling even at the showground well.
There's plenty of an aide was left just anywhere at the showground. And i'd be oddly very much a guy just a festival.
Restarting like it was then because it's risky even walking a bit now and.
What will it be like with or with a bigger crowd.
And the drugged out ever same to them so just like i know plenty of free to be just as many months now as it was one
thing. I just. Not of anything really that. What real good the first of all did do.
And i knew him when he was so small and. Probably yelling back. But it has brought business and that into him.
But when so many very rough and. You lie about people.
You've got a job even to work on the straight because there are so many.
They sit around her lying around
and i doubt even mike room for all these two would clear particularly for the stroller or.
Shopping shopping trolley ok.d. Stroller or not there's billy room to get past them.
Or cut or concepts down a really lot of good.
A lot of good when in doubt you you i did find there were some very good musicians among the. The new set list and.
Very very talented in music and. Sometimes i quite often join them. I do a lot of singing.
And i still do it at seventy no seventy nine and some tell me all kinds of people are like me the come along
and sing while i do the banking and. I really enjoy it but i just can't think of any special. Time i had with them.
Occasionally though. Not so long back i performed on the nimbin show ground and.
I joined in with them and quite a few times with leather and.
General public in general really enjoyed a couple of special times i can remember with them.
But some of the songs that. With people if they don't know them. If they don't know them themselves like.
I have music and they can follow them but why. Some of them are quite up to date.
Country western songs such as one day the time and place help me on falling in.
The girl dies here die and also the pearly shells and i usually say here comes the name
and by a law i was in the telling was. There's only one but a lot of us. And on very happy that.
If i sound like you but i'm not you either try and labor has really i mean one
or thought i can do the other the good ol laurie songs or the oldies all in general.
The bing crosby's go i buy produce at one time don't know if anyone wants gospel songs will they come to the right
place because i like and sadly sadly handle the gospel. I'm doing it regular at the moment in the way.
All the local churches. Went to sydney recently.
Graeme souness wearing the the man there was saying a special one for his wedding with so i did.
And i was just coming back from a lovely weekend in intent of saying
and who attend the first ever plus three other three other avenues
or the three new citizens with five things songs in three that i so i think about coming home for all of that i guess.
We don't just stop. Yes.
So it is a
and i was in one hundred seventy three i was in oh i'm don johnston in back in nine hundred seventy three
when the aquarius festival was mooted i was our idea we farm here at bishop's creek which is near noon been and.
I was also and. I can plot on the terrain is your council.
Which later become amalgamated with a little more city council. We did my guy.
Decision back in seventy two just before the course first of all to allow the festival. To be held in him been.
And that's about a five on concern the situation would have possibly been that there were only three or four. Did.
Object to the yard. At the public meeting.
That they shouldn't have their careers first of all the rest of nimbin seem to be going along with it.
So that's where they train each our council made the decision to allow to be held and.
Looking back in those days or feel would only one thing that we should have done.
And that was probably to put our bigger bond. On the festival. Committee because the clean up program.
Looked a lot to be desired in the trying to assure our council had to pick up the tab for it. Yes i was around.
For all of the festival. I was also president of the nimbin bowling club.
And they first of all was right beside it and. My wife was heavily committed to our church organization.
Having me also our soups and and teas and running other for the people who were visiting the festival.
And so i was committed. Every day and every night.
At the club and help helping organizations and even taking in the some of the visitors.
To their camps and one another during the not. It was different it was most certainly different.
I feel that the young people most of the young people that were there.
Didn't really understand what they were there for. That was my first impression of a lot of the people.
But they certainly enjoyed themselves for those ten days that they were there.
And most certainly they were helped by everyone in name and to try to join in and be part of it.
These are some of the funny thoughts were probably the first time that we saw in a lot of people getting around with no
clothes on. Even in fairly. Populated streets and money another.
I don't think too many took a great deal another stop it. But i do believe that some of the things and.
One of the things that have come from what i believe.
Was a presence of drugs they are doing now that the local constabulary and i told them.
Told the committee that they would not be hard on them if they only used soft drugs such as met marijuana.
But one thing used hard drugs i would claim down on them which they did and.
I can remember one distinct episode where i group of people. Could be number twelve or fifteen hundred.
Got box cutters and. Cut the handcuffs off. A prisoner that i detected had.
Not really very little fighting between themselves or with anyone else.
It was a really good time there was lots of really good music.
And a lot of good times for most of the people concerned or. There were they only those isolated.
Actions that i believe i did did my right but not to any great extent.
Well the good things i left i believe there are some very talented people in the area and.
Probably stem from the aquarius festival or. Have got.
Media coverage seems a lot of people with great talent in arts and crafts we have some very good craft shops
and workshops in the village now that can be put down those. From the aquarius festival.
There's also probably a lot of money. Being generated by the people there. Whether or not it's because of.
Doll of because to be invalid pensions or whatever.
But the result lot more money in nimbin at the present stage in the world back in not before not in seventy three.
Yeah. Niman. Lot of people say it was i becoming a ghost town i don't believe that for one moment it was going through.
What we'd call i probably a recession. It was just coming to the stage where we had some. Total of about one hundred.
Dairy farms in the area. We had our own but affect tree.
That will fill by the wayside that we're just trying to deteriorate.
We had about four or five mills in the area one mill in a time. Had twenty id employees.
And now we're back to one mill so yes there has been i decline in.
Industry and i think that's the big problem that we've got in nimbin at the present stage.
Not enough in industry and it.